dell partner stein der 2013 in ägypten
gefunden wurde ist ein ganz besonderer
stein er ist kein gewöhnlicher asteroid
sondern stammt zumindest in teilen nicht
aus dem sonnensystem aber woher jetzt
wurde er genauer analysiert und
offenbart ein sehr seltsames innenleben
klicks und science fiction herzlich
willkommen
ja schon bei den ersten analysen des
steins wurde erstaunliches zu tage
gefördert der hypatia stein besteht in
seinem inneren aus diamanten und es war
sehr schnell auch klar
dieser stein bzw bestandteile kommen aus
dem interstellaren raum wir hatten ja
letztlich hier über den ersten
dokumentierten vorbeiflug eines
interstellaren objekt berichtet dass so
seltsam war das ein außerirdisches
raumschiff nicht ausgeschlossen wurde
und das objekt auch darauf hin
untersucht wurde der hypatia stein ist
so seltsam dass er wohl aus
bestandteilen die von außerhalb unseres
sonnensystems stammen besteht wie
seltsam sein innenleben ist das wurde
jetzt von einem forschungsteam der
university of johannesburg in südafrika
untersucht und es ist tatsächlich
verblüffend nicht in und an diesem stein
gleicht einem stein hier von der erde
oder aus unserem sonnensystem dabei sind
die enthaltenen diamanten noch ziemlich
gewöhnlich sie sind wahrscheinlich durch
den hohen druck beim aufprall auf die
erde entstanden und sie haben dazu
geführt dass der stein so gut erhalten
ist aber was sonst noch so in dem stein
enthalten ist das ist nichts mit nichts
hier aus dem sonnensystem vergleichbar
die zusammensetzung ist ganz anders
zitat aus der untersuchung die mineral
matrix des steins unterscheidet sich
deutlich von allem was wir bislang in
anderen meteoriten gefunden haben selbst
wenn wir die gesamte erde zu staub
zerkleinern könnten so erhielten wir
eine durchschnittlich gleiche chemische
zusammensetzung dieses staubs wie wir
sie auch in sogenannten schon tritt
meteoriten finden in konkreten erwarten
wir einen kleineren anteil kohlenstoffs
und einen größeren anteil siliziums aber
in der matrix die partnerstadt finden
wir einen großteil an kohlenstoff und
einen ungewöhnlich kleinen anteil von
silizium zudem enthält der stein ein
anteil polycyclische aromatische
polizisten den interstellaren staub
befinden die mitglied georgi berlin
untersuchte das innenleben des stands
genauer und schießt auf etwas wirklich
verblüffendes reines aluminium das gibt
es auf der erde gar nicht und kommt
wahrscheinlich so auch nirgendwo im
sonnensystem vor und weitere substanzen
enthält der stein mit denen so niemand
gerechnet hat die gesamte
zusammensetzung des steins lässt für das
forschungsteam jetzt nur einen schluss
zu der stein kommt nicht nur aus dem
interstellaren raum ebenfalls bestimmte
anteile und diese bestandteile die sind
auch älter als unser sonnensystem und er
ist bei sehr niedrigen temperaturen
entstanden wahrscheinlich so bei minus
196 grad celsius ja und seine sehr
exotische zusammensetzung die wirft
jetzt einige fragen auf wie ist unser
sonnensystem genau entstanden also aus
welchen gasen wie sieht's bei anderen
sternen systemen aus wenn die
zusammensetzung so anders ist dann ist
vollkommen unklar wo er entstanden ist
ja eher wird der wissenschaft wohl noch
einige zeit rätsel aufgeben und ob seine
herkommt überhaupt geklärt werden kann
das ist mehr als ungewiss wenn er über
die neuesten erkenntnisse dazu
informiert werden wollt dann drückt nun
aber aufs auge und vergessen ich den
genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr
auch über neue videos informiert hier
geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
interstellare objekte moore rätsel
gelöst ja ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran